I youtube i'm body shy from india here
at the tower's program i had been
attending a number of sessions which are
related to how did we come to response
as far as the Western nations of her son
and the economy and to me it's really
fascinating we have such a wealth of
incredibly intelligent and important
people how did they allow trillions and
trillions of dollars to get white done
and I went to one session yesterday a
key thing that seems to be coming out of
there is completely ignoring the lessons
of history and what happens when greed
is about to go completely among as it
was in the kind of bonuses given to
people to sell junk there are many many
angry coming soon but just to finish it
out if we have so many people educated
so expensively and with so much
experience the better prize winners but
they open together could not get this
avoid this whole problem now it remains
to be seen but are they going to have
growth of 1% of 2% in the world but it
looks like a very difficult time but
Lisa next five or ten years thank you